so most people see bees as pests and
want to kill them as quickly as they can
Dennis langua of Orlando Florida has a
very different approach he is a Humane
bee removal expert he's been doing it
for more than a decade he's known as The
Bee guy he joins us to explain why he
takes this approach Dennis thanks so
much for coming on well I see I see
you're protected
um so why people see bees they want to
spray them with a can of poison and kill
them why should they not do that
well two reasons number one is as a
homeowner the last thing you want to do
is leave a bee's nest inside your
structure it'll cause more problems than
you could ever imagine
and the other reason is because they're
honeybees and so rather than having them
killed there's a beekeeper that would
happily remove and relocate those bees
and we do that all day every day
so how do you I mean I I'm just assuming
that bees don't want to be gentrified
and move to a new neighborhood so how do
you convince them to to leave
well it's a physical process so we
essentially evict them we physically
remove their nest putting it into a
beehive and during the process we use a
special vacuum designed to vacuum the
bees up and not hurt them and once
they're brought back to the farm then re
relocate the bees from the vacuum with
the nest and put everybody back together
and put them to work
how mad are they when they get out of
the vacuum
you'd be surprised at how gentle they
are so most of the time we don't have to
wear a suit or a veil or any protective
clothing during the entire process
because they're just totally defeated
like they got vacuumed at that point
they just give up it seems like they
should sting you no that's not
now it's just a matter of knowing the
insects and keeping them calm
how important and obviously you're you
have a reason to promote bees I'm very
protein myself I'll just say it but why
are bees important
well they produce one third of the food
we eat at least and of course they also
make honey which is a sweet delicious
treat everybody enjoys
so if you if if any group if we're to
locate any group in the world that
produces one third of the food we eat
we'd obviously want to treat them like
they were private Equity Barons or hedge
fund managers like we'd treat them with
a lot of respect but we don't why I
would think so
I I think it's just some people have a
fear of bees and their knee-jerk
reaction is when they see a nail they go
get a hammer yeah I think that's right
or a can of bug spray how much honey do
you eat
foreign
honey and ice cream but you're obviously
you're wearing a full suit we can't
really see your outline but you seem
like a pretty slender fit character how
do you eat honey every day and maintain
your girlish figure
I work hard every day I wake up at 5am
and I don't stop until about 6 A.M
yeah well you're making the world better
unlike most people maybe even talk show
hosts so Dennis langwa our respect to
you thank you for coming on tonight